Here we are inside the CSS documentation on Bootstrap's website.
Inside the images section, we find something about responsive images.
This is what we want.
We want our images to be responsive-friendly.
It looks like we only need to add the img-responsive class to make sure our
images are, well, responsive.
Let's see if that works.
Let's go ahead and open up DevTools.
And I'll go ahead and try it out on this image.
Booting it up.
I've got image here.
I'll right-click on it, add attribute.
So we've applied the class img-responsive to this image in particular.
Let's go ahead and resize the page and see if it works.
I will make it smaller, and smaller, and
smaller until we're about the size of mobile.
And because we've added that responsive image class,
you can see the entire image fitting within the width of this small frame.
So, the correct class is img-responsive.